hey everyone it's tequila from tasty and
today i'm going to tell you about one of
my recipe videos that almost broke me my
2020 new year's eve cake
man was the struggle real in that test
kitchen so i was doing some research and
i stumbled upon these really awesome
hidden message cakes they're pretty much
regular looking cakes on the outside but
once you slice into them a word or
symbol is revealed i wanted to see if i
could recreate it in the tasty kitchen
when i thought about the inside of the
cake one of those magic eight balls came
to mind you know the wines you shake up
and you ask questions like will i be
successful or am i going to find love
soon and it gives you predictions like
all signs point to yes that's kind of
where this idea originated i wanted the
cake to have words around it that spoke
to good fortune and the inside of the
cake to be the eight ball prediction as
to when those things would happen the
only problem is we had no idea if the
cake would read 2020 or if the inside
would be a squished hot mess
the concept for the cake was simple bake
one cake slice it punch out the numbers
place those into a larger cake and bake
that one but the execution was a little
bit tricky so i requested carly to make
the cake on the day of the shoot that
way i could just focus on capturing it i
didn't want to mess anything up
especially since this cake took so many
tries to get right in the test kitchen
during the development of this recipe it
seemed practically impossible to keep
the numbers from folding over on
themselves since the sprinkle cake
batter kept crushing the numbers carly
incorporated egg whites to make it a
little lighter on the numbers then she
tried freezing the numbers to help them
stand up to the cake but try after try
the inside of the cake was just nothing
close to resembling 2020. then carly
thought of brushing the numbers with egg
whites to reinforce that freeze and that
seemed to be the magic touch but it took
about six attempts for the recipe to
finally work and when it did we were all
relieved and ecstatic at the same time
during the shoot everything was fine
until the slicing of the finished cake
that's when anxiety kicked in for sure
would the cake read 2020 the only way to
find out was by slicing into it when i
saw the cake actually read 2020 i was so
happy the numbers were perfectly in
place and that we achieved what we set
out to that was a win for me then the
video received 50 million views in one
week i could not believe my eyes it's up
to over 60 million views now it just
goes to show that even when things
aren't going exactly as planned it
always helps to have hope so just keep
that in mind for 20 20.
thank you carly for sticking with me
through this recipe and thank you all
for watching
oh yes
[Music]
you